[Musique]
m
on
c'est une super soirée
je te l'avais dit que les mecs raffoler
des show déjanté vous regardez quoi ne
sait rien elle envoie des textos un mec
avis c'est à moi de lui dire je veux
seulement être mieux classé avant pièce
à détruire et 5 en premier je suis
triste j'ai un assistant bonjour que
puis-je dire je n'arrive plus à me
connecter et je pense que votre site
diffuse d'anciennes d'image ou alors
rien n'était pas possible n'avons pas la
capacité de faire ce genre de chose
qu'est ce que ça indique que c'est en
direct
oui madame on est revenu
sonnés par mois la copie-conforme va
racheter ton qu'on sait clock équipe
déjà prévues sont faits pour nous tester
mais c'est quoi
j'ai vu à sept jours pour deviner qui va
choisir
mais je sais pas ce que je fais tu m'as
pris mon visage et je te promets que je
vais le récupérer tu m'as pris mon
visage je te promets que je vais
récupérer
[Musique]
m
tu veux qu'on s'est mis un peu
[Musique]